Washington journal annotated good
morning editor of this book how to make
black America better let me begin by
referring to one of the chapters or one
of the essays that you include in this
book by marian wright edelman who says
that every five seconds during the
school day a black public school student
is suspended and every 46 seconds during
the school day a black high school
student drops out every minute a black
child is arrested and a black baby is
born to an unmarried mother every three
minutes a black child is born into
poverty every hour of black baby dies
every four hours a black child or youth
under 20 dies from an accident and every
five hours one is a homicide victim it's
powerful it is provocative and that is
the kind of stuff for lack of a better
word that we have throughout this entire
book in putting together this book how
to make black America better I recognize
that at 35 I don't know much anything
and so it was important to me and
incumbent upon me I think to reach out
to a variety a broad cross-section of
black Americans thought leaders and
opinion-makers about what they think can
be done to help make black America
better as you know the book starts out
with ten challenges that I have written
that I think every black American must
meet and accept if we're serious about
making black America better but once you
get past my ten challenges you get into
these rich and provocative essays from
all sorts of people on the cultural end
people like Shaquille O'Neal and Magic
Johnson and hip-hop artist dr. Dre and
Chuck D and Tyra Banks and Deion Sanders
and you go all the way to the other end
the deep intellectual is the marian
wright edelman is the Cornel West the
Henry Louis Gates Jr is etc and there is
no peace in this put more provocative
than the piece of grand Rite Edelman
rights she is obviously the children's
advocate in the country and it seems to
me if we're going to make black America
better we have to change the children it
has to start with the children and I
would not think of putting a book
together about how to make black America
better without the contributions of
Marian Wright Edelman Henry Louis Gates
Jr who talks about the kerner commission
back in nineteen sixty-eight in which in
essence said there were two nations in
this country one white and one black is
that still the case without question
there Stewart to America is
unfortunately one black one white I'd
like to think that because we are now
living in the most multicultural
multiracial
show multi-ethnic America ever I'd like
to think that pretends well for the
future I'd like to think and I think in
fact the case will be there because this
new generation of young folk in America
has grown up not in the same construct
as so many of us grew up in that black
white construct the paradigm has shifted
so to speak I'd like to think we're
going to make some make some progress on
race relations in this country given
that reality but Gates's pieces per is
again rich in the sense that he talks
about the furthering that piece about
the black bourgeoisie and those African
Americans we have done well who have
achieved much and the responsibility
they have there's nothing wrong with
being a che nothing wrong with the being
successful being black sometimes I think
black folk who are successful to make
you feel guilty because there's so many
other black folk who are still trying to
come up gates rights and suggest there's
nothing wrong with being black and
successful you shouldn't feel guilty
about that however there is a challenge
to privilege we cannot act as if because
we are up here and others are down here
within our community that somehow our
destiny is not inextricably tied
together so you're right it's a piece
that really does provoke thought
challenge those who are black and have
done well to do more and to recognize
and all of our destinies are tied
together as always we welcome your phone
calls Tavis Smiley will be with us until
the top of the hour born in indiana
morning in the morning Mississippi
actually I don't want to get were my
friends down there born in Mississippi
right there in the Gulf Gulfport Biloxi
area but my father was and for that
matter still is in the Air Force and so
I when I was about two years of age he
was transported from place called
Keesler Air Force Base in Mississippi to
a place called Grissom Air Force Base up
in north central Indiana and unlike most
Air Force brats to be around all the
time and we pretty much stayed put in
Indiana from the age of two all those
years because my parents had 10 kids I
have nine brothers and sisters and it
would have been without question and
undo economic hardship for us to have
moved around 10 kids all across the
around the globe and so we stayed in
Indiana which I think I've wondered
oftentimes whether or not I would have
enjoyed my life more had I've done like
my other Air Force friends who were
moving around the country around the
globe of whether or not i think i got
the the best of what was there by
staying put in indiana i think upon
reflection that
got the best out of being stable and
environment with friends and family in
one place I love the opportunity to have
grown up in India in your book you
talked about you have two sisters right
through sisters yes and the three of you
never moved back to your parents home
after you became adults precisely but
she said that your other brothers did I
don't to put words in your mouth but you
seem somewhat critical of that well I I
try to make the point in one of these
ten challenges that we have to put
family first and I try to explain what I
mean by that in the chapter but the part
that you asking about specifically I
referenced the fact that I have seven
younger brothers and at any point and
time all seven of them have moved back
into my mother's and father's house at
some point once they left the house and
the plows trying to make is that part of
putting family first means not indulging
people in there and in their foolishness
and my brothers I love them all dearly
and support them it would do anything
for them but the point I'm trying to
make is that too often we Harbor people
we we we give them all the everything
they asked for we give them stuff quite
frankly they don't need sometimes making
a man responsible is pushing him out
there and saying go do your thing you
can't come back home as a refuge every
time something goes wrong every time
somethin good way you want it to go you
can't come out to mama's house and my
mother over the years has finally come
to understand that you can't have a
revolving door in and out of your house
not if you ever want these boys to grow
up and to be men and so part of what we
do in a black community with this
extended family thing which is good in
some ways but challenging in other ways
is I think to harbor people when they're
not doing they ought to be doing because
we don't have the courage to push them
out there and let them swim they're not
gonna drown push them out there let them
swim if they need to come back home for
a certain period of time that's cool but
don't let they don't let there be
revolving doors so that such that we
don't build a responsible attitude in
the hearts and minds of young brothers
and sisters where is the name Tavis come
from my aunt um named me I had it on my
mother's sister who was apparently in
Texas at the time that my mother was
pregnant with me and talked to her on
the phone one day and suggested to her
that if I was if I were a boy that she
named me Tavis and I don't think my
mother ever got the full explanation of
why that on
was later murdered and we never got a
chance to ask her what Tavis was all
about where that name came from but I we
think she had met some man maybe in
Texas named Travis and like the name and
suggested to my mother's you didn't meet
avarice what's really funny about you
asking that question now we're in the
middle obviously of a big book to do
about 22 stays on to here and I have at
various points on the tour on this book
had the pleasure to meet a couple of
kids who have been named after me people
who found the name interesting for
whatever reason i'd have named their
kids tabish so it's been kind of funny
to me I never met anybody in my life I
know a lot of travis's but i never met a
Tavis until going on this to of late
I've actually better couple of kids
who've been named Travis how was your
aunt killed murdered actually was
murdered murdered and a tragic situation
and if this was in Mississippi many many
many years ago and it speaks to a number
of things not the least of which is how
we treat a crime in inner-city
communities she was murdered by another
black man who was in prison for a matter
of days quite frankly literally wasn't
in prison for a year so he was out back
on the street they're talking about
recidivism which is a legitimate issue I
think for us to be discussing in today's
society but I wonder sometimes whether
or not in Mississippi the races of the
persons involved had been different
whether or not the outcome had been
different I to this day do not
understand how somebody murders somebody
and within a year they're back walking
the streets again I think though that it
was a mindset you know they were both
black people in Mississippi crime at
that point apparently between in black
communities wasn't a priority for people
to deal with and so he was back out on
the streets and today is still out quite
from Boston good morning good morning
good morning I'm calling I'm sorry I'm
late but I'm calling about the taxes the
one tax that they never mentioned is the
text that they put on unemployed people
that was beginning in the 80s of
homelessness people got unemployed poor
people and they never made enough money
to get back to work again that's the one
text that should be removed on
unemployed people thank you you know one
of the it's a good call on one of the
I think great contribution is around
Reagan made and for those who follow my
politics no I'm not around a Reagan fan
but I think one the best things Ronald
Reagan did was to establish to foster
quite frankly the earned income tax
credit when Gingrich and the republicans
took over the house in 94 that was one
of the things on their list they were
trying to do away with Ronald Reagan
himself called the earned income tax
credit for pool working families the
greatest anti-poverty program in
American history those are Reagan's mr.
conservatives words and yet Republicans
years later tried to do away in this
mean spirited away with the earned
income tax credit and so I think the
call is right if ever there were attacks
that we ought to get away with it's on
those people who can least afford to pay
the Earned Income Tax Credit on the
other in the spectrum is something that
helps poor and working families those
the counter programs that we ought to be
fostering new york city for Tavis Smiley
good morning good morning morning mr.
smiley I like to listen to you I want to
ask you a question make a statement and
ask you a question based on that what I
think and I'm very optimistic about this
I see the unraveling of the big lie in
this country starting to come about I
see a kind of some truth and clarity
shining on what the left has been doing
in this country for about 30 years now
one of the problems was with the
organizations like the National
Organization for Women now or the people
for the American Way during the Thomas
Clarence and the Robert Bork hearing
starting with pork they told 72
documented lies documented by orrin
hatch they tried to smear if they use
the erase card and everything else to
stop pork they weren't allowed to stock
Thomas and now they're doing the same
thing with the John Ashcroft and what I
see happening is that people are
starting to because we have other
outlets besides the elite media you have
foxy and NBC which are world by the way
soaring in their ratings while ABC CBS
CNN they're all going down because
they're still trying to use these
web swing tactics do you have any
optimism that uh that will get more of
this in the next four years possibly
will start getting back to some truth in
rewarding it's a good question i
respectfully disagree with your
assessment I don't think there is any
elite media I don't think there is this
liberal media bias there's so many
people like to act as if that exists I
don't think it's about a liberal media
bias at all i think about capitalism
folk who want to get paid and so people
print the kinds of things they think
that we want to read when you talk about
these 72 documented lies you say they're
documented by orrin hatch I would
question anything that aren't hatch
documents given his his own ideological
leanings and the agenda that he in fact
as a Republican senator is trying to
push I will tell you this on the john
ashcroft earrings which you raised and
your and your comment concerned me i am
not an ass croft supporter I do not
believe that mr. Ashcroft ought to be
the Attorney General of these United
States I think what he did to Ronnie
white the first black member of the
Missouri Supreme Court was reprehensible
he originally promised to support Ronnie
white and then he found himself in that
tough reelection campaign against the
late mr. governor Carnahan he realized
he needed to do something to shore up
that conservative vote in his state and
so he demonized this black man Ronnie
white who had been nominated for a
federal appellate position I don't think
in the name of political expediency we
turn on people and then distort the
record and demonize them you might have
seen mr. y testifying last week here in
watching here on c-span doing those
confirmation hearings I don't believe
that John asked car was the right man to
run dodge Justice Department and I am
concerned that too many Democratic
senators are about to give a pass to mr.
Ashcroft when if only on race issues
alone he ought not to be confirmed in my
judgment I'm concerned about that these
Democratic senators concerned that they
might lose the conservative vote in
their state many of them well knowing
people like toys sell you out of New
Jersey max cleaning out of Georgia
understanding i think that they cannot
be reelected without the
african-american vote and so they are
disrespecting all those black voters by
giving a scoffer by considering even
giving
Crawford pass on these raised questions
how long have you been on Black
Entertainment Television five seasons we
are three are not fit seized on bt and
doing well next call is from Grand
Rapids Michigan good morning good
morning you want you to have a savage
it's like to say you are really really a
gentleman and you make me proud to have
you as a brother because I am a black
American woman like and I would like to
thank you for speaking speaking out
against Jesse Jackson's wrong that he
did you know I think that's important
that we take responsibility as black
people for our problems that we do cause
you know to one another because as being
black we have responsibilities to each
other you know and and I have black sons
and I would like to raise them you know
in a responsibility of you know helping
our black people instead of harming each
other and so add the black mother as a
black of sons nowadays how do you help
them against the racial profiling that
they you know suffer and you know help
them to always say stay strong and not
you know defeat themselves and you know
trying to go the clue sure Thank You
phone call the question you raised by
racial profiling is a legitimate
question once again another reason why I
think that mr. Ashcroft is not the
appropriate person to be a friendly
general do not get a sense from anything
he has done or said in his entire career
that he would pursue an aggressive
agenda against racial profiling I don't
care whether you're black or white
Republican liberal when people are being
pulled over because of their race being
pulled over by cops because not all cops
certainly most of them are doing a good
service for us and I wouldn't want to be
a cop my hats off to anybody who gives
up service as a law enforcement officer
but any of us I think has to find
reprehensible the act of certain cops
pulling over people just because they
happen to be african-american to the
question you raised about your comment
rally about Jesse Jackson I have said
they've been quoted saying that Jesse
Jackson is a public servant and not a
perfect servant I believe it's possible
to have more faith
and still provide leadership on dr. king
martin luther king jr. for my money is
the greatest american period that we
have ever produced and yet dr. king
himself had issues if we're going to be
honest about it if Bill Clinton to leave
the White House with a 65-percent job
approval rating and having been voted
just a few days ago is one of the most
admired Americans if Clinton can do that
certainly River Jackson I think deserves
some love I do not believe that because
we make mistakes no matter how
catastrophic that we ought to have for
the rest of our lives those mistakes
smear us or to cast aspersion on all the
good that we have done or all the good
that we can do i would add the right
quick they're one of the ten challenges
in this book Steve other ten challenge
in this book is that every black person
must consider the consequences of their
actions and in that regard I must say
the Reverend Jackson disappointed
obviously not just himself not just his
family but indeed black America because
to ultimate in african-american messes
up all the rest of us get painted with
that broad brush and so we have to make
our leaders understand that they must be
responsible for their actions that when
and as James Baldwin said that race is
not a personal reality or a human
reality race is a political reality so
when Jesse Jackson makes the kind of
egregious error that he made too often
the rest of us get painted with that
broad brush so we must hold our leaders
accountable for their actions at the
time when this child was about to be
born or was a couple months old Jesse
Jackson was advising Bill Clinton on the
Monica Lewinsky affair reaction to that
well I think Reverend Jackson has some
some questions to answer about that that
question has come up and an ordinate
number of times the question of the
hypocrisy questions i called it i saw a
piece of the jack white road in Time
magazine other day but after the number
of people raised this particular
question I think it's a question the
Reverend Jackson ought to answer I think
that long term the Reverend must be
concerned about his credibility and I
think that particular question and the
issue have been raised about the money
there are questions out there that are
floating obviously I don't tell Jesse
Jackson what to do but if I were the
Reverend I think that there's some of
these questions that are so troubling
that I would certainly sit down at some
point in time and at least once address
these issues and say that I've addressed
them and refer people to the tape if
they need to see the interview but I
would think in terms of giving them
advice if I
ask that the best thing you do would be
to sit down and address these questions
because what you don't want all these
rumors and innuendo and innuendos
swirling forever around your head
because you won't sit down and address
these issues he has so far released a
statement said he's not going to say
anymore and that's his private about you
know if he does that God love him if it
were if it were me though I would want
to sit down at some point clear these
questions up so that my credibility
doesn't keep being attacked for the rest
of my life we're joined by Tavis Smiley
who is out with a new book on the state
of black America and he also has a
symposium that we will be covering next
Saturday februari the third here in
Washington called the state of the black
Union guests include Cornel West Kwazii
and pume the Reverend Al Sharpton who
else bishop TD jakes quite soon for me
at the NW CP Hugh price of the Urban
League just a the brain trust much of
the brain Chester black America there
has not been a gathering yet of
african-american thought use and
opinion-makers since the election of two
thousand to talk about what black
America is going to do what is our
agenda going to be over the next four
years and so we will bring all these
people together and to have a national
conversation about what our agenda ought
to be we know mr. Bush's in the White
House there's some people who are scared
to death about that I don't know whether
we should be we'll find out he said he
wants be a president of all the people I
know that he went through the entire
campaign and did not address black media
so I have some concerns about them
they're all kinds of issues i should
also say it's not just these are not
just black liberals we have Ken
Blackwell the republican secretary of
state of ohio we have joe rogers the
Republican black Secretary of State in
Colorado Reverend Kirby John Caldwell
who introduced mr. Bush at the
convention and gave the prayer a closing
prayer at the inauguration will be with
us Alphonso Jackson on african-american
Republican clothes printed mr. Bush will
be on those panels as well so we have
latest reporters gore supporters bush
supporters all kinds of foam coming
together to be a part of the symposium
next saturday and will be live again all
day saturday februari the third next
call is Millington Tennessee good
morning come on gentlemen good morning I
have a question of submit the smiley
regarding what I perceive to be
that's the way the class system is in
this country is based on economics I
noticed through my life I'm in my mid
40s and I've noticed that there are
people who are wealthy and and they tend
to stay on one end and the people who
are not as wealthy and middle-class you
know they hold the blue-collar jobs and
some of them struggle in poverty
basically and I was wondering I thinking
about what you had said earlier in
regards to helping people and and within
the black community and and and keeping
people from pretty much falling out of
the mainstream economics society how
would what are your thoughts how would
you accomplish that because it's
something that I see pervasive
throughout the United States I think
you're right and we thank you for your
call we address this in the book I
mentioned earlier that I reached out to
a number of folks stretched out to all
kinds of folk who a much brighter than I
am to write these essays tackling these
tough questions these social questions
these political questions these economic
questions Earl graves for example the
publisher and founder of black
enterprise magazine America's leading
magazine for those in business rights
and provocative essay in this book about
just how we do that how we convince
african-american families how we help
african-american families to establish
an economic plan I believe that while we
could discuss issues like racism until
we're blue in the face I believe that
racism is one of the most divisive
issues in this country but until we do
something about this economic gap that
exists as i said earlier between the
haves and the have-nots indeed within
the black community there has that have
nots we've got to do something about
this economic gap booker t washington
once said that the bottom of all of our
struggle our political struggle our
social struggle at the bottom of all of
our struggle as black people must be the
struggle for economic independence and
so i am even those who in the movement
those who are who are leaders in the
in the struggle offer freedom in the
black community understand that the
paradigm has shifted that we really do
have to build a new construct the fight
these days is no longer just about civil
rights civi l it must also be about
silver silv er rights and so we've got
to work at the same time to advance an
agenda of civil rights but also silver
eyes to make sure we shrink this
economic gap and we lift those out of
the bottom rung who are who are
disenfranchised economically can you
point to one black American alive today
who you think is the best role model for
young people oh I think there are many
there's no shortage of role models in
the black community I write in this book
though that Charles Barkley you recall a
few years ago started a huge furor on
talk radio in this country when he did
that commercial for Nike where he said I
am NOT a role model you're allowed for
who don't like the term role model they
they suggest that because they are any
particular profession they're doing
their job they're not asking to be
didn't want to be a role model they
don't they don't like being placed on a
pedestal so a lot of athletes and others
who don't necessarily like the term role
model in the black community having said
that I argue in the book that you might
not be a role model but you are a race
model because you are an
african-american you get judged whether
you like it or not it's not right it's
not fair what I call the it theory it is
what it is and because you are
african-american you are judged by the
way you behave or misbehave so you might
not be a role model but you are
certainly a race model Alexandria
Virginia good morning good morning at
the honor talking to mr. smileys thank
you sir I admire your support for
Reverend Jackson I know he he laid his
life on the line for all of us white and
black to receive to you know bring
racial equality i also have been
listening to mr. Ashcroft and I I
support you on that I mean I don't
support Ashcroft but I wonder he's sort
of weasel wording he's not lying but
he's saying he won't overturn Roe vs.
Wade do you think he's not against
homosexuality but yet I think he is
can't figure how he's wording his words
and I'm pretty sure he'll get in but can
you clear so you are very astute and
thank you for your phone call I've
noticed the same thing as you will know
when people are going through
confirmation hearings they're most
likely to say anything the spin that he
keeps putting on this is that while he
does have he has not denied of course
that he has strong personal views but as
attorney general he argues that he would
uphold the law that's the distinction he
keeps making between how he's going to
separate his personal views from the job
he must do as a professional as the
Attorney General presumptive in some
people's minds attorney general of these
United States I'm with you I'm not so
certain i'm buying that and again one of
the things that you have to admire about
john ashcroft if you are at a strong
supporter I am NOT but if you ought to
ask cross supported one thing's got to
admire about him is that he is a man of
conviction is very very difficult for
people who are convicted and who stand
by those convictions and you can't have
it both ways and that's that mr.
Ashcroft was trying to do he tries to
tell us and all of his life's work that
he is a man of conviction he does things
he believes in because of his strongly
held convictions and yet once a
confirmed as attorney general all of a
sudden all of a sudden those convictions
go out the window and he only does the
job he's supposed to do I'm not buying
that and I don't think you should either
Oh late Kansas is next for Tavis Smiley
good morning good morning finally I'm
from time to time watch the et
television and quite honestly I'm
appalled at some of the things that I
see there and my concern is that I think
that the black pop culture has to a
certain extent coarsened white culture
in this country and I some of the things
that I see I believe that if there are
eight nine and ten eleven year old
children watching what they see on b.e.t
which is probably what they are watching
I think it's creating an incredible
problem for blacks in this country who
want to set a different set of standard
your opinion on that let me surprise you
um I agree with you I absolutely agree
two months of what we see on television
this is where i'd make the make an
addendum to your statement
too much of what we see on television is
not what young kids in America ought to
be saying my identity is it's not just
on b.e.t it's on MTV quite frankly it's
on ABC CBS NBC fox it's on television
period a children exposed to stuff they
ought not to be looking at these days so
I can't let you just disrespect or or
bag b.e.t their other networks as well
who I think all of them quite frankly
are challenged to to give us better
programming challenge to do better by
America's Kidz the studies abound as to
how this mess for lack of a better word
that we put on television every day is
messing up the minds and the behavior
patterns of young people so it's not
just a black entertainment television
thing I host the show on bt every night
not do everything I can with that
program to try to enlighten to try to
encourage and to try to empower those
who watch but i think that there's a
lack of balance in how black folk are
portrayed in television and that's not
the fault of eet the problem is that
black people are betrayed in one way
there's a whole dimension there's a
complexity to black life just like there
is to white life or any other life the
problem is on television all you get is
one slice of that lives but it comes to
black folk for example on television all
you get are comedies you don't get drama
DS you don't get shows that show the
complexity the range of who we are as
black people television in general is
challenged to do better in that regard
how many homes received eet 60 million
next call is Elizabeth New Jersey good
morning good morning morning a man
amongst them I'm money Providence is
that we seem to have to apologize to him
for everything that some of some black
people do and for all the leaders that's
out there today when Martin Luther King
was out there he was in the trenches he
was in these neighborhoods with this
young black youth he was teaching them
how to grow up to be a man I'm not to
bend over get somebody let's about to be
on their back to stand up straight but
we on TV as the so-called leaders they
do a lot of talking on TV but they never
comes in the neighborhood and do what
they suppose to do fear there's a lot of
kids out here I hear people saying
that you don't have a father I would
rage without a father my brother raised
eight head of us without a father none
of us went to jail all of us have our
own homes have our own families are we
doing great that thing about without a
father that's what excuse does a lot of
white kids without a father but you
never hear about their it's always about
the black kid that's what bothers me
okay I respect your phone call and I I
understand your sentiment one of the
things in this book and the reason why
we wrote this book how to make black
America better is because you talked
about leadership a moment ago let me
take that point I think that too many of
us are looking for some messianic figure
waiting for somebody to crack the clouds
one day and come back and deliver us to
the promised land many of us truth be
told I have been who had been wandering
in a maze since nineteen sixty eight
when dr. King was assassinated not
knowing which way to move what the next
step was many people are worried now
that Jesse Jackson's credibility is
taking a hit because he is the leader of
the movement I say with all due respect
to all black leaders that the movement
is bigger than one man the movement is
bigger than one woman we need to have a
playbook and when something happens one
of our leaders we turn to chapter to the
next page and we keep on moving because
the movement is about us it's not about
one particular person I tell the story
all the time and right there in this
book the big black is like flying on an
airplane you know we've all heard this
message before you go on the plane they
tell you in the unlikely event of a
sudden loss of air pressure the oxygen
masks will drop from the compartment
above your head they take to take that
mask and put it on yourself first before
you assist a person seated next to you
we've all heard that the point is simple
you can't help anybody else in black
America unless you first help yourself
so it's not about the news it's not
about who's in the Oval Office it's not
about who's running Congress it's about
what we are going to do as individuals
to make black America better and that's
what your family is done and that's what
all people of conscience do they control
their own destiny by doing what they
need to do to better their condition and
you begin by saying you think black
first one hundred percent of the time
whenever we engage in business deals
whenever we have work for hire or
contracts to be shared or even if we're
doing something as mundane as shopping
which
tell ourselves I must find someone black
for this job and you point out to buying
black designer clothes instead of those
from Ralph Lauren or tommy hilfiger yeah
I think you could do all I'm not
suggesting that those who like Ralph
Lorenz shouldn't buy it those who like
tommy hilfiger shouldn't buy it but I am
suggesting is and this is not rocket
science if you talk about making black
America better every action begins with
a thought I argue in this first of these
ten challenges but if you're African
American every day you have to wake up
with a conscious thought that I want to
do something today in some smaller
significant way I want to do something
today to help make black America better
sometimes a simple thing I don't know
what we went wrong we used to not walk
past one another and not speak not smile
not acknowledge one another that's not a
black thing that's an American thing but
since this book is about making black
America better i underscore the fact
that we've gotten away from the general
courtesy of just acknowledging one
another's presence that's a simple thing
you can do to make black America better
included there are more significant
challenges that confront our community
but the point is every day if you wake
up thinking black first that is to say
thinking what you can do today as a
member of this race to make a
contribution to contribute then I think
black America is better off see you bye
Sean puffy combs clothing Sean John well
I personally don't worry I'll John but I
know there are a lot of kids who do wear
designer clothes and the image that's
put forth in the media is that it's
hipster where he'll figure more than
anything else it's hip to where Ralph
Lorenz more than anything else these
white designers truth be told use black
models to sell their stuff because they
know that they're really reaching an
urban audience of kids who buy this
stuff like nobody's business and again
I'm not suggesting that you ought not to
buy whatever you want to buy I am
suggesting if you are black you have to
consciously think every day with your
purchases and everything else you do is
there a way today that I can help
improve the state of black America
better and too many of us are abrogating
that responsibility every day st. Paul
Minnesota good morning with this color
come on the air you sure are good
morning excuse me I'm a little nervous
here first time caller
uh first of all I'd like to say to mr.
smiley I think you're a perfect example
of reverse racism you don't like white
people it's pretty obvious I can finish
here though you've mentioned something
about Ashcroft here you said that
because he didn't appoint one black on
this court judge thing that he was not
fit to lead but yet you said Jesse
Jackson Jesse Jackson was it was okay
for him to lead because because of his
sin I don't understand that one man can
one man can one man's white one man's
black first of all thank you for your
phone call even though you were wrong
about everything you said respectfully
some of my best friends are white folk I
work with white people every day I have
nothing against white people and that is
the kind of groupthink that you put
forth that I think damages America I
don't cast aspersion on people and
obviously you weren't paying attention I
don't cast aspersion on folk just
because they're white or Asian or black
or anything else that's the problem I
was on CNN yesterday I'm seeing in
yesterday having a conversation about
black leadership and again around this
question of Jesse Jackson is something
wrong with black leadership as black
leaders have gone astray and I had to
make the point on CNN yesterday as out
make now there's not about black
leadership it's about leadership there
are black folk who are leaders who make
mistakes just like there are white folk
who are leaders who make mistakes Bill
Clinton Rudy Giuliani had an affair I
mean oh you know people are human we're
not human and divine with just human so
full make mistake but let's not paint
all the black leaders as wrong are all
the white leaders anymore as wrong
because they're white or black so it's
not a it's not about black and white
it's about wrong and right and the
reason why I suggested ashcroft ought
not to be Attorney General is not
because just because he denied this one
man an opportunity to be a felon
appellate judge it's because john
ashcroft really the way he did this is a
racial arsonist he used
issue of Ronnie white as a political
expedient way to shore up a wing of his
voting base to make sure that he would
not lose that election he lost it anyway
and he lost because african-americans
and Missouri understood that and they
turned out in record numbers to make
sure the Ashcroft did not win reelection
to that seat so it's not about the sin
you know I'm not suggesting that Jesse
Jackson should do anything that's his
business what I'm suggesting is that
when you play the Rays game you do not
need to be Attorney General the book
published by Doubleday it's edited and
compiled by Tavis Smiley how to make
black America better next call is Boston
good morning hello yes Tavis yes I just
want to let you know that I do want your
program in the evening and I think is
wonderful and one thing that you do do
when there are issues that are facing
the black community your show is there
to address that but I also want to make
an opinion that I feel very strongly
about you do have this book of how to
make black better here in America but I
just want to say this someone's name
that you have not spoken of and that's
the Honorable Minister Louis Farrakhan
is many many things that he has done as
we take to me and me and much the
million family much and even ask
starting from the Million Man March
there was many marches afterwards to
bring the black community together to
come together as a family or for the men
to take charge you know of who they are
and take response to them selves if you
are a regular watcher of our program as
you said you are and I thank you for
that then you know that I've had as a
guest on our program the minister louis
farrakhan as a matter of fact when we
started our season this year our fifth
season on opening night we had our first
tied up as I guess the Honorable
Minister Louis Farrakhan talking about
at the time plans for the million family
march that were coming up talking about
his his survival his beating back this
prostate cancer that he had also I've
had him on the program and there is no
question in my mind he has done
tremendous work specifically with regard
to helping restore african-american me
and they're all kinds of
who I know and impersonal friends with
we've got their lives back on track as
black men because of the teachings of
Lewis park cars I've cast aspersion on
his work he's done great work certainly
in that area and I applaud him for San
Antonio Texas good morning yeah good
morning mr. smiley morons Nora look with
you quite a few years ago and I don't
think you know I agree on too much
politics I do respect the attention I'm
on a military officer so most of my
friends that are black are very
conservative like myself and I was glad
to hear that you're going to have some
more conservative types at your meeting
that's coming up and I think that's
where black America can really make a
lot of progress in this country you've
got to be on both sides of the aisle and
and I would hope more people leaders
like yourself would speak up for
conservative blacks I think one of the
problems we have in this country and I'm
not saying you do it but there are a lot
of good conservative blacks that get
branded as some type of I don't hate
used word Uncle Tom but that's almost
what it's like and it really bothers me
because I think this country we all come
together if we pray for each other and
we can work together and I think we need
discourse on both sides of the aisle and
keep up the good work okay thanks for
your phone call I I certainly agree with
you that the black committee is not a
monolith we can agree to disagree
without being disagreeable obviously
those my friends who are black and
conservative we tend to disagree on a
lot of issues but i think that the
conversation is good we've invited them
to be a part of this symposium on on
c-span here next Saturday I would only
add that that there are number of
african-americans or who have a problem
with these so-called black conservatives
who oftentimes get pushed out front as
if they speak for black America and
that's where you have to draw the line
nothing wrong with them having their
ideology as long as people don't confuse
the fact that they have not been elected
to anything in black America so they
have their own viewpoint they're
entitled to that viewpoint quite frankly
a quick study of history remind one that
black folk have always been as the
people we've always been more
conservative on the morrow questions and
more liberal on the social questions
that's just true a black folk across the
board so there is this conservative
currently on moral issues that runs
through black America and we stand proud
i think around that
the problem is and the problem arises
where the image just gets put out there
that JC Watts for example speaks for
Black folk he's black but he's not
elected by black folk in his district
and so he does not speak for black
America he's not been elected to
anything in black America Thomas soul
doesn't speak for black to make the only
point I'm making is they are entitled to
their point of view our respective point
of view will argue them on certain
things obviously but don't be confused
don't believe the hype don't get it
twisted they do not speak for black
America they do I have a following in
black America and that's the only
distinction I think that needs to be
made to come on Washington good morning
hi hi Pavel hello how are you I'm glad
to be on with I'm glad to be on with you
I wish you at eight o'clock and watch oh
I miss being audio eight o'clock he
changed my time slot we're now on at
eleven thirty eastern time 1130 Pacific
and 1030 central time yeah but I agree
with everything you say and regarding
your your question how to make black
America better I've been thinking about
this issue for a long time because I do
work in the community one thing that
will make black America better is when
we are integrated into our society not
assimilated well we don't portray or we
don't put forth lies in our educational
curriculum when we can open education up
where we see not just black history
which is not there we are a part of
America I don't agree I thank you for
your phone call I couldn't agree more
the fine tradition of the black church
let me just say a man and leave that
where it is Seneca South Carolina you're
our next color for Tavis Smiley why do
they move your time slot by the way the
programming you know I don't got all
those the programming decisions at any
network are made out of pay grade much
higher than those of us who are call
talent so I don't control programming
they moved it and I'm just trying to do
the best I can with that time slot go
ahead caller thank you very much and let
me say mr. smiley I appreciate what
you're doing for your race I'm kind of
interested in we do contain your book
and read it and so my best friends are
black people all right I like to
but I want to share with you I think
that uh what you're what you're saying
about mr. Ashcroft you're saying he's a
man of convictions and strong
convictions and and not adhering to
those convictions would be hard for him
and I must say I believe that from what
I know of mr. Ashcroft is one of his
convictions would be honesty and when he
took an oath to uphold the Constitution
United States enough hold the laws of
this land I believe there's not a man in
this country that wouldn't do a better
job he's honest and he's integrity and
that's the kind of person we need his
personal convictions on certain issues
he's an American he's entitled to those
that I respectfully disagree with you
and I won't belabor the point I made the
phone earlier that i am not a NASCAR
supporter certainly mr. Bush has the
right to appoint anyone that he wants to
a point but I think what's building here
and you gotta pay attention to this in
the media and and watch this what's
building here is a ground swell a
groundswell of community people who are
opposing the Ashcroft nomination this is
not an elitist movement this is not a
black movement it's not just women
there's a movement building here in the
community in the streets grab the
grassroots level there are people
starting to come out and oppose john
ashcroft the fact that they preach this
boat back by a week I don't think
pretends well for mr. Ashcroft I'm not
want these persons who believes that
it's a foregone conclusion that he is
automatically going to be confirmed just
because he was a former member of that
deliberative body the US Senate but I
believe that if those of us who are
serious about this Ashcroft nomination
hearing not being confirmed start to let
Congress know let the Senate know how we
feel about this I believe there's a
chance that Ashcroft in fact might not
be confirmed but of course time will
tell on it not the California your next
good morning hello napa california
alright this is Joshua Tree California
and I think we slipped in here kind of
funny but anyway I have a question or
mr. Chavis about I'm a member that the
afl-cio union and also we we have a
boycott going against the BT network and
Mike
I'm curious about where you stand on
this or if you could give any
information on this we have we have a
boycotted and uh curious about it I do
believe you know like in our union we
work we work blacks whites Hispanics
Orientals all work together to try and
better ourselves and uh why the point is
a ry the boycott uh that's what I'm
wondering I was wondering if you had any
integration I don't I am let me just say
first of all I am a union supporter
number board number two you're asking a
question about labor issues again some
of these questions are questions that I
can't answer because their issues that
are out of my purview I'm just a guy who
host a talk show every night and I don't
I don't do it labor issues at the
network and so I can't respond to the X
I don't know anything about it quite fun
and author of how many books this is my
fifth one how to make black America
various book number five Mesa Arizona
good morning mr. smiley my star how are
you fine I'm a Republican okay and I
enjoy watching you on the talk shows
thank you only problem I've got with you
sometimes you talk faster than my ears
oh you know everything you beat these
Republicans you got to talk faster this
on me and man what can I tell you I
think though that some of the black
community leaders need to change their
thinking just a little bit when the
Democrats red power go for your programs
when the Republicans are in power think
like a Republican ask them for
investment seed money to start new jobs
and in the end companies thus jobs in
the in the inner cities and investment
seed money like a bond issue that they
underwrite and banks and liberals and
Republicans and anybody can invest in
those bonds and that money can be used
to bake jobs money is what it's all
about you know I respect your phone call
and don't disagree with anything I think
you got to work with the times you gotta
shift it move your agenda forward given
who's in the White House and I think
that black America is prepared to do
that when and where we can nobody what
nobody wishes mr. Bush ill obviously we
don't want to suffer for the next four
years so anything we can do to improve
our own condition by working with the
administration in those areas and arenas
where we can work together
I'm all for that the problem is that
when you're black though and you try to
get a business start you talk about seed
money yes there's some of that out there
there's always a little bit out a little
bit out there but I sense he is it and
I've said many times before that I don't
have anything against capitalism I'm all
for that don't throw the only thing
wrong capitalism is that they always get
to capital and we get to Islam you know
the racism the cronyism the good-old-boy
ism I am an african-american obviously
and I can tell you as one who owns his
own business and have friends obviously
long their own businesses there's
awfully difficult to get started I mean
the difficult part about anybody getting
in business is getting some access to
capital and whether we like it or not
whether we want to accept or not because
racism still does exist in this country
it is awfully difficult and challenging
it more often than not for
african-americans to find the support
they need to get into business in the
first place much less to stay in
business what's your business what my
business is Tavis Smiley we have lose
letter we have books we do symposiums
are all kinds of things my biggest is
advocacy I'm in the business of trying
to make a difference and anything I can
do through radio through my television
program my radio commentary my books
appearances our whole effort is gear
that will be called the three es trying
to enlighten trying to encourage and try
to empower people through any number of
things that we do through our company
called the smiley group go back to your
home state birthplace of Mississippi
Philadelphia Mississippi good morning
good morning mr. smiley morning sir I'm
well how are you sir I have a question
for you that possibly you can answer I'm
a retired military officer I noticed in
the military that officers are not
referred to as black Chinese or whatever
but rather officers are by the rank or
by their name this worked in the
military rather well why are people
referred to in our society as Chinese
Americans Japanese Americans Irish
Americans are black Americans there's no
question my father is a military man and
there's no question that the military
has been one of the one of those
institutions about racism a game does
exist I get letters all the time from
folks in the military
issues about a variety of things they
want me to be aware of but the military
has been one of those readings where if
you were in african-american you could
still get a better than a better than
average chance as compared to the real
world of trying to succeed and not being
held down just because of your race
clearly people like colon pal are
examples of that so the military is
better on these diversity questions I
think then than many other institutions
of our society are although they are a
long way from perfect obviously there
are rules of engagement their rules why
and the military people are referred to
in the way that they are a by their
reign those rules don't apply to society
and even those in the military I think
you've been callin power will tell you
that even as successful as he has been
he still had to succeed against the odds
and african-american officers to have to
do the same thing so the military is not
a perfect place as I said my father is
in the military and I know all too well
the struggles he's had to endure some of
those struggles around questions of race
and so I don't want us to think that the
military is a perfect place to be but
certainly I think are doing better than
other institutions of American society
now I don't look too much into this but
I just noticed your cufflinks are those
smiley cufflinks oh you're responding I
work I what I like I like wearing
cufflinks i rhythm every night on
television and what happens is all most
likely ride talk to Larry King one day
people say no if you can see this I get
it general you can you seriously put
your arm over here Robo cam you see
there is there is a happy face yeah um
Larry King you know people wear
suspenders every night and people send
them suspenders all the time and people
see me wearing cufflinks on television
every night and so as I travel around
the country or just just in the mail
every week people send be coupling so
somebody given that my name is smiley
sent me a pair of smiley cufflinks and
their o'clock and they actually work so
i can check the time and two people up
during the day by waving on like this we
have a few minutes place according to
those cuff link that's the clock Tucson
Arizona good morning good morning I have
a question Molly it's something that
I've been wondering about for a long
time a couple of weeks before the
election I read an article on the front
page of the New York Times
which said that Mr Al Gore was being
sued for racial discrimination by Secret
Service agents on the basis that he had
requested is that the number of blacks
on his detail be limited and thereby had
created a glass ceiling for a number of
the black agents whose next promotion
would put him in line to be on mr.
gore's detail and and he had made it
known that that was not an acceptable
situation for him my question is do you
know where the suit is going and why
does that not bother black people at all
you you are totally opposed to mr.
Ashcroft on the basis that you suspect
he's insensitive to blacks and yet you
totally embrace and support Al Gore who
is in fact being sued for racial
discrimination and I find that hard to
compute as you know first off thanks for
your phone call as you know we live in
the most litigious society in the world
and just because one is sued doesn't
make it so that's number one secondly I
was aware of the story obviously and we
reported the story talked about it in
fact on our television program on b.e.t
when the story came out so the story was
not swept under the rug at least not in
black America at least not on black
entertainment television where I work so
we did cover this story secondly thirdly
as I recall mr. Gore denied any
knowledge of that and decried that kind
of behavior if in fact that existed at
the time that was his statement i only
share with you what he had to say I was
here I'm paraphrasing his words finally
I do not know what the status of that is
I take all any issue of racism and
discrimination seriously as I think as
Americans we all should but if your
question is what ever happened to the
suit where it stands now I can't tell
you I do not know few more calls in our
remaining minutes with tavis smiley of
b.e.t and now out with his fifth book
Nashville Tennessee good morning hi
hello okay hi mrs. smiley how are you oh
where are you I'm just so happy to be
talking to you I'm Nevada Department um
i would just first i say embrace a
couple of comments that some of the
previous collars it made and I'm
especially in regard to being
integrating blacks into society I think
that that is a common problem in this
country everything has to be black and
white you know although there are other
races represented everything is always
black and white and I think just the
power of the human race in this country
is over simplified by the race issue
totally and I'm an african-american and
I have a number of white friends black
friends and my daughter and son you know
has many friends as many cultures that
they go to a school- or a school where
they are embraced with many races and
they I haven't even thought my children
any of these issues because it is so
unimportant to them and I wish that the
rest of America could kind of see that
the whole point in us even being here is
accomplished the exact same thing
everybody's working everybody's bringing
up a paycheck most people have children
a house closed they need to eat you know
we're all here for the same purpose
listen to the sister on the phone call
and I wish I knew who she was I wish I'd
found her stevo a few months ago so I
would have asked her to write an essay
in this book how the big black America
better I argue there in the premise to
this book introduction that when we
struggle will we make an effort to make
black America better we by extension
make all of America better when we work
to redeem the soul of black America I
think by extension we would gain the
soul of all of America your comment
makes me mindful level of a cute little
saying that i have on in my office that
says that if racism is such a learned
behavior then why do we keep teaching it
if racism is a learned behavior then why
do we keep teaching it and I think
that's awfully poignant the words
particularly in light of the comment you
made about what you are not teaching
your kids about this race question but
that's a good that's a good line I like
that if racism is a learned behavior and
it is while we keep teaching to our kids
moline illinois good morning yessir what
we have to do to make America better not
only black America and the way to make
America better is to follow the rule of
law on january sixth the Black Caucus
out of the Senate chamber or the house
well rather when we were trying to elect
a new president he won in Florida by
rule of law he won the electoral college
by rule of law and your caucus walked
out I'll stop they'll get a quick
response the Congress walked out in part
because they think that the way this
thing went down was wrong you're right
we live in a nation where we ought to
respect the rule of law with all due
respect sir the most basic and
fundamental rule of law in this country
is the principle of one-person one-vote
if we can't respect that rule then there
is no law because we are the law we are
the rules and the rule is very simple
one person one vote we got a respected
there a number of african-americans
indeed in the CBC the congressional
black caucus who feel like in Florida
and so in other places but certainly in
Florida that rule of law was not
followed very end the reason why they
walked out last call for Tavis Smiley
from Queen Institute West Virginia good
morning yes good morning good morning
mr. smelly I'm raising two young men in
this nation my children dress black and
I am raising them to be black what is
dressing black I'm you know they say
dress the rap way okay the headband I
got gene outfits that they like the
label I only ask you dressed islands
only asked why you say dressing black
because you know the white kids dress
the same way these days exactly our kids
of you differently when they put on the
same closer I got okay that's uh as a
child being raised as black with wait
you lived in your society and then you
lived away white society expected you to
live in making America better we always
want to judge people on the color of
their skin how they look how they react
how they talk even now they walk okay in
order to make America better especially
in the black communities their black p
black leaders okay have to look at the
issue of these hidden racism ways
which society is not dealing with
minority classes thanks very much yeah I
don't know exactly she was speaking
about no we have to run but she says
hidden racism i said earlier that i
believe racism is the most intractable
it is the most egregious it is the most
divisive issue in this country make the
mistake about it racism alive and well
but the file analysis which i think is
there is the point of this book and the
final analysis the best thing that we
can do to eat racism the best thing we
can do is black people to eat racism is
our because our continual and daily
pursuit of excellence and everything we
do there is no better answer to remedy
racism that us continuing to pursue
excellence and everything we do every
single day that's what this book is all
about how to make black America better I
hope that this book starts a
conversation will be a catalyst for part
to our catalyst rather for a real
conversation about what we can do to
make black America better and how can we
how we rather can can excel every day
with everything we take on the book by
Doubleday 2195 I think that's what they
tell ya I guess I don't do I don't the
prices I just final me what about to
Tavis Smiley thanks for joining us and
again a reminder that he will be hosting
a symposium a week from tomorrow here in
Washington and we will be covering it
live all day starting at nine in the
morning it's called the state of the
black unions impose IAM and again the
guests include Cornel West equation fool
Mayhew price bishop TD jakes iyanla
Vanzant all kinds of foam thanks for
joining thank you my pleasure